no do you donate blood no you donate
anything no you don't believe in
donations no what about Salvation Army
do you donate a Salvation Army Goodwill
yeah that's tight I just throw it away
because they don't deserve it
[Music]
does anybody here watch Korean dramas on
Netflix no only thing I've seen is uh
all the popular Korean I've never got
into it but my mom was watching that one
where they give the eye
oh the OG one it's called the high not
though it's that one drama where the he
gives the eye to her the one from that
music video is that a music video that
one there's like a old viral music video
but I thought that was a show I don't
know oh maybe but I might be just mixing
up k-dramas but there's a K drama called
Snowdrop and this actress Park SU ryun
that's her
it's pretty popular she's pretty popular
she's in a lot of stuff yeah so she was
just arriving home walking
on some stairs she fell and died oh my
God just from literally falling down a
flight of stairs was it a long did you
hit her head or something what was it
like three stairs she hit her head yeah
she basically was uh you know like when
you hit your head at that velocity yeah
she was brain dead and then uh was
unresponsive her heart however was still
beating and I think the most remarkable
part of this story is that like one of
the most selfless things you can do as a
parent her her parents were like okay
she's not gonna be revived mentally her
heart's still beating we should donate
her heart while it's beating wow
wow so someone else can have it what a
thing to think
and just think I don't know yeah so it's
very pragmatic still yeah while her
organs were still alive and well they
opted to donate to a person in need wow
and they got it to somebody yeah that's
incredible dude that's a really [__]
sad story when people get transplants
from other people they start to absorb
characteristics of the other person they
start showing like things that they
never did before and then they really
yeah for any organ yeah it's like uh you
got liver transplants you're just become
an alcoholic or like you get what it's
like and then you're like why do I want
drinks so much I didn't even like
drinking and then it's like oh the
person that you got this from
was a drunk bum
oh sick
I like that this doctor would just say
that straight up oh that's a drug bomb
sliver
oh it's really nice oh I don't think
buddy give me a math the quality of a
drunk bum's liver would probably not be
great would would you guys be down to
donate your organs are you all organ
donors I'm an organ donor I think I
think I'm an organ don't do it it's a
scam is it
should I change it wait wait do you mean
what do you mean
uh so all that [__] is like donated
right but they're making money off of
your money like your body parts like
they're like they're making hella
[__] money yeah you give it away but
they make the money they make money oh
dude I don't want to get my organs away
then because even even with blood is
kind of like that which I thought it was
weird where like you donate blood right
and like it's like you get like a
[__] liter of blood every year yeah
when you need blood they're gonna charge
you for it it's not like there's like
some sort of credit system where you're
like oh I don't need it three times the
credit system would be nice hey no
wonder these [__] email me all
the time to donate blood because I just
don't let all the time I donated blood
like once and um like I saved someone's
life so I don't like Prague or anything
but they sent me an email they probably
send it to everybody but then when you
need blood you're gonna charge it I know
what the [__] is that about they gave me
a bunch of snacks though give me a bunch
of Nutter Butters they give you cookies
yeah I'm down with that snacks are tight
if you're hungry just give them blood
and then you eat cookie
do you donate blood no you donate
anything no no you don't believe in
donations no what about Salvation Army
do you donate a Salvation Army Goodwill
yeah that's tight I just throw it away
because they don't deserve it yeah I
read okay I don't know if this is
correct I agree let me know if I'm wrong
I read somewhere that Goodwill is not
even a charity Loki I think they're
scamming bro really I thought I heard
that too they're not for-profit
companies yeah that they're not even
like uh they're not a fool it just looks
like they are but they're just a regular
business I've heard some people say I'd
rather burn my clothes than give it to
Goodwill really why would they say that
I don't know I think they just got a hot
take them out don't they I don't know I
like how cheap they are because like
every Monday they have a tag sale and
every whatever that color that tag is
it's a dollar that's tight that's pretty
cheap that's just fun dude I don't I got
this whole golf club set you guys saw
for twenty dollars wow because each Club
was 20 like a dollar one of my friends
got a rower you know like that cardio
machine for 80 bucks at Goodwill and
he's sold it for 600. people do that
they flip yeah the same world you got me
oh really the yeah and you got for 80
bucks I'm like man I should have shot
that Goodwill first wow somebody got rid
of that at Goodwill yeah and he got it
for 80 bucks concept two that's fine
that's like the rare situation that you
find something that you're getting
you're able to you know what's not a
rare situation that's a a very
dependable Goodwill flipper if you want
to do snowboards snowboards snow gear if
you if you go to Goodwill in the summer
and you just buy all the snow related
gear you can resell it in the winter for
amazing profit wait a season one time I
was at Goodwill and this is when I was
training at the gym and I was uh uh I
was teaching kickboxing classes one of
the members her name was
for the sake of the story her name is
Sherry okay or not for the sake of the
story what's her name Terry okay yeah
Terry her name is Sherry now but she had
these boxing gloves that were like beat
the [__] and one day I was at the
Goodwill and they were selling those
boxing gloves the exact same so she gave
it away and it had her name on it oh and
they were selling it for like like 10
bucks and let me tell you did you buy it
and then give it back to her no I
actually did it but these boxing gloves
were so beat to [__] the fact that they
even put up for sale is crazy and they
smelled they were like ripped up and I
was like you guys can't get away with
selling this for [__] ten dollars
yeah and that's when I was like I'm
never donating it yet no I still don't
know I don't know I think like one of
those they they don't actually give a
lot to the people I bet that's probably
true there's no yeah dude you're a
really good flipper of items
yeah this guy he's really good at like
hustling Goods yeah yeah like if you've
seen his I wish I could show you guys
one day I got lucky enough and I found
his offer up and it was the best day of
my life really his his ads are so
[__] funny he's got the sales pitch
in the ad oh yeah yeah it'll be it'll be
like I know you you go everywhere you
see people charge you 80 bucks for
something like this you come to me 40
right now like the whole thing yeah it's
all written out and it's for like a like
a Spider-Man toy
it's so good that got me fired up dude
he goes no [__] you come to me I
give it to you this right no [__]
well I look at everyone else's price on
that thing like a Honda Civic I got a
free Honda Civic from my buddy a free
Honda Civic yeah yeah these stunt guys
were getting so wealthy and they're like
yeah just take the car and I was like
[__] yeah I need it just take the car
yeah just take the car so I took it and
everyone sent it for 55.6 and I was like
look that offer up right now they're
going for 55-6 mine's 45 and it's all
yours instantly hey amigo me can I get
your can I get the car okay
he's a master seller [__] dude you're
getting the sales bro there's like his
ads literally will start with I know
what you're [__] thinking too good to
be true right no it's true this is only
eight like it's so great for furniture
stores yeah yeah like and it's in all
caps and [__] well it's also it's also
at night like when I like to post it at
night because when people do see it at
night they're you're more you know
you're more in the zone at night you
know because you're about to go to sleep
and you're just like oh [__] and then
you they message you and be like
tomorrow morning I'll be there and then
they go to sleep I'm gonna buy that [__]
and they don't spy it in the morning bro
these people are on offer up in bed like
this yeah and then when they see subbins
they go holy [__] yeah
45. I tried well you got buyers coming
in at like three in the morning because
they're right about to go to sleep and
they're like holy [__]
come in at 10 or midnight
they're just trying to run it in I'm
like hurry up hurry up buy it buy it get
the [__] out of here hurry up
did you ever have any bad experiences
with sellers or buyers
no nothing is everything I write about
it it's true no like them trying to scam
you yeah you never got like messed with
someone trying to ask you on a date
yeah does that ever happen to you oh you
know Ali no no
someone like Colleen should handle it
when the buyer is trying to date her
give me some um tips have a dude sell it
for you can you write my descriptions
for me oh yeah dude I'll get that [__]
just get his descriptions my photos oh
that's easy wait you're a photo in my
description
when they come to pick it up just jump
with my hair down how's that how's that
eight percent almost say no not eight
percent I just want to see if my
description
[Laughter]
he's like I don't want to cut that's
literally he doesn't want to cut it's
dado dude
to me he offered me
um he's like hey I only have this much
and I was like all right
um sorry it's this price and he goes
okay fine that price I was like what the
[__] just happened
holy [__] you're a master negotiator all
right cool yeah meet me here
it's a whole game you're good you're
good what were you selling there's a
chessboard oh tight yeah you know what I
realized too you can't sell fake money
on OfferUp
it's illegal I feel like I'm an idiot
for not knowing that did you get in
trouble money the prop money you can't
spell prop money even if it clearly says
prop money and you say that it's prop
money and it's for production it gets
taken down immediately every time oh
okay and like my account was gonna get
deleted for continually posting oh [__]
because we had that big giant bag of
like fake cash yeah that's good for
Productions but you can't sell it it's
illegal to actually sell you you have to
make it for yourself yeah even airsoft
guns you can sell Airsoft no unless you
draw orange tip on it like once you
screenshot it and say it's a Nerf gun
so if you look at if you type in Nerf
gun you're going to see airsoft guns oh
wow you want to know the you want to
know the ultimate sad hack on um OfferUp
and Facebook Marketplace about selling
dogs if you're a backyard breeder yeah
they sell the cage or stuff like that
and then they just be like the uh cage
for Golden Retriever yeah yeah it says
dog cages and then the next photos the
puppy's always in the frame but it says
dog cages so yeah if you guys run into
that it's not a dog cage it's the actual
dog
I mean why is that sad because back in
the day on the Penny Saver they would
just have ads of free dogs yeah
but you just you know you built it up or
they'll be like chow chow for fifty
dollars and then you show and then back
then there was no picture so you
actually had to drive to their house to
show up and you're like that's not a
Chow Chow that's a pit bull
I would have been down
[Music]
oh
foreign
[Music]